hello everybody welcome back to another
matplotlib 3d tutorial in this tutorial
we're going to be building some
skyscrapers not really but that's what's
going to look like so anyway let's go
ahead and hop right on into it the first
thing that we want to do is import the
necessary imports and these imports are
going to be from MPI underscore toolkits
and plot 3d import X's 3 capital D next
we want to go in pour Matt plot lived up
pipe plot as P ot and I import lovely
numpy as in as we get further into all
these kinds of tutorials you're going to
start to really just adore the creators
of numpy there's so many cool things in
numpy that just make life so much easier
continue it on figure equals plot figure
nothing new there and then we're going
to define our axis 1 equals fig dot add
underscore sub lot and it's going to be
1 1 1 and a projection equals be nothing
new here besides obviously the 3d
tutorial section so what I'm going to do
here and kind of explain right before I
start coding this is with bar chart it's
not the same as a plot like with the
plot chart so far we've had an X of Y &
Z that was it really
because a plot is just literally a
singular position on a chart where as a
bar chart really has more than just XYZ
it's got like an X Y Z and then like
another X Y Z and probably the best way
to say this is like an X Y Z and then
you've got a delta X Delta Y Delta Z
right how much has how much is it from
that one plot and then it changes a
little bit to another plot right so for
example you've got so if you don't quite
get the delta part and it's where do you
start your XY z-- and Z's and then where
do you in
the X Y's and Z's so if you're not quite
following just yet luckily this is all
completely visual so if you don't quite
understand just yet
you'll be able to kind of toy around and
I'll do a little bit of twine around and
kind of drive that point home otherwise
just play with the numbers a little bit
and see what like different
visualization pops up for you and you
should have no problem kind of
discerning what's going on so with that
let's go ahead and continue we're going
to have these are going to be our
starting our starting positions right so
you're going to x position equals and
then let's make this easy we'll just do
one two three four five six seven eight
nine and a ten next we have Y position y
starting point now we're going to do two
three four five one six two one seven
and a two now the next thing you have is
a z position now first I'm going to show
you guys the literal looking Z position
and then I'm going to come through and
show you guys from now on the way you
ought to do this but in order to
understand exactly what we're coding
this is what we're going to go ahead and
do just fill it with zeros next and you
might know the proper function to do
this but I do suggest you just fill it
with zeros for now so you can follow
along with the tutorial because Z
position does matter for this tutorial
the next thing that we want to do is
define our changes our Delta X Delta Y
Delta Z and so on
so we'll say Delta x equals and for this
we're just going to say uh one but there
is a function for this built in the
numpy which you just do NP dot ones and
then you specify how many you want and
we want tanks that's how deep our array
is so what this is going to do is for DX
it's going to set array of ones in the
length of hang so now we're going to do
same thing with Delta Y it's going to be
equal to
he ones ten and then we're going to do
Delta Z and just to kind of make this an
interesting looking chart we're going to
go a 1 2 3 4 5 6 8 9 and 10 and also
again this is so it's a little easier to
follow along and understand what's going
on here if you don't already so now we
want to actually plug this so plotting
is s 1 dot bar 3 D so it's just you know
we're gonna it's almost just like a X 1
dot plot right it's just our 3d tells it
hey we're going to we're and throw this
funky stuff at you so x position Y
position Z position Delta X Delta Y
Delta Z and you could just do this but
let's add some color to it make it
pretty we're gonna set color equals and
in here as always you can always put in
a hex code so we're going to do 0 0 C e
a a it's going to give us kind of like a
lightest blue ones like a cyan prawn and
plot show so say that will run it
hopefully we get any typos I hate when I
type of a charts nope
so here is our 3d chart looks awesome
now to give you an idea about a couple
of things before we change things up
first of all as far as like scrolling
around and zooming is concerned it's all
the same that we've already kind of
covered so anyway the next thing I'd
like to show you guys because I've
zoomed now it's not on the bottom let me
see if I can get this zero back on the
bar there okay so now let's see if I can
get to the point yeah so see this how
they line up one two three four five six
seven eight and real there is a ten I
promise there it is
so the what's happening here this is our
Delta variable right remember that that
Delta change if we bought back over here
Delta X Delta Y Delta Z see how we did
one two three four five so nine ten now
what if we did um 10 here and now we'll
save that will rerun it pop back over
and all of a sudden no doubt this one's
messing up it's not part of the steps
this is it suddenly these stairs are
unusable
anyway so that's a delta X that
hopefully you can start to understand
Delta X now now what if we're going to
return that back to five now the other
thing I was saying was about these
positions now normally you would just
say you it for the Z position you would
use the MP zeros because right all we
really wanted was bunch of zeros so for
Z position and the reason we want a
bunch of zeros actually let me go ahead
and just show you that let's replace
this with a three now we'll save that
we'll run it and you'll see one of these
yep one of these stairs now starts at
the three obviously we're not seeing let
me see if I can zoom in yet now we got
the three there so as you can see it's
starting at three so the Z um start
point is a three and it's still changing
by a delta of four right but it starts
at three and it goes all the way up to
seven so just to give you an idea so
like if you want to do like a stacked
bar chart like I mean that's a valid way
to do bar charts then you would want to
utilize the Z positions but if you're
not doing a stacked bar chart then you
would really just do em P zeros and you
want ten of those save that and you
would run it and sure enough we're back
to our you know steps are beautiful
steps so anyway that's how you would how
you would go about doing either a
stacked bar chart or just a regular bar
trek sighs so I imagine a lot of you
guys just want to start at zero for Z
but it's really helpful to know that you
can start at four right and then you can
start building stacked 3d bar charts
epic stuff so anyways as always thanks
for watching thank you for your support
your subscriptions and until next time